Speaker 1: The Joe Biden White House is now
facing what is absolutely the biggest foreign
policy crisis of the still relatively new
presidency and administration of the Biden
White House, there has been an absolutely
terrible terrorist attack in Kabul, Afghanistan.
This is part of the broader context of Joe
Biden deciding to make good, essentially on
the plan that Donald Trump claimed to have.
Now, of course, Donald Trump ultimately did
not leave Afghanistan, essentially ran out
of time, but as far as we knew, planned to
leave, just like Joe Biden ultimately decided
to do.
And this is one of those areas where if you
are looking for the sort of simplistic black
or white Manichean analysis of what is going
on in Afghanistan, there's plenty of places
to get that.
There's no question about it.
And we've seen many of those simplistic analysis
analyzes come from the usual suspects, the
paid political consultants on both right and
left for different reasons.
We've seen them come from the military industrial
complex, friendly, generally pro-war corporate
media.
And by pro-war, I don't mean they want war
persay, but they want conflict and salaciousness.
And they know that military conflicts generate
ratings.
And unfortunately, all of those analyzes fall
short.
And there's good and there's bad and there's
right and there's wrong.
And it actually requires a little bit more
thinking in order to get something approximating
a view that considers the totality of what
is going on.
So we'll work backwards.
Thursday, two explosions happened in an area
right by the Kabul airport.
This is an airport that has become a central
location in what is now taking place in Afghanistan,
which is many people trying to leave.
There are Americans trying to leave.
There are locals trying to leave and seek
asylum or refugee status in the United States
and elsewhere.
As you are seeing the Taliban increasingly
prevent people from leaving to some degree.
And also now we have introduced ISIS, ISIS
claiming responsibility for the two explosions.
These were suicide bombings as of this morning.
The latest numbers were one hundred and eighty
two people killed, including one hundred and
sixty nine Afghan civilians and 13 members
of the United States military.
These are the first military casualties in
Afghanistan since February of twenty twenty.
Joe Biden was meeting the remains of the 13
deceased American military members when they
arrived in the United States over the weekend.
So let's go through each item here, because,
you know, it's actually kind of a bummer.
I know that we're going to get really simple
black or white analysis from most in the media.
The right is saying this is all terrible because
Biden's incompetent and Trump would have done
it great.
Well, no, he would have won.
No, no, he would not have.
Some on the left are saying this was carried
out the wrong way.
Biden was wrong to leave or just this is perfect
and everything has been gone swimmingly.
All of these takes fall short.
Joe Biden was 100 percent correct to leave.
Afghanistan doesn't change anything about
that.
Joe Biden was completely right to leave Afghanistan.
This does not mean as a result of this terrorist
attack that we go back in my preference.
Right.
Of course we might.
I don't believe it means we go back in, but
it does mean that Joe Biden has a crisis to
deal with here.
Now, for those saying this crisis is what's
tanking, Joe Biden's approval and this crisis
is going to prevent Democrats from winning
in twenty to twenty two.
I disagree and I disagree on both.
And we're going to go into that more tomorrow,
the political implications of this part of
it as voters have a very short term memory.
Part of it is foreign policy actually matters
surprisingly little when it comes to how people
vote in elections in the United States.
We'll get back to that.
But the fact that after just a few days of
the United States pulling back, you have the
Taliban taking over and then you have ISIS
versus the Taliban.
This actually reinforces how completely untenable
our involvement was in Afghanistan.
We have to stay forever in order to prevent
this.
That's proof that we shouldn't be involved,
since the only way to keep things even relatively
calm, apparently, is to stay involved indefinitely.
It's not viable.
It's not viable unless you believe in the
United States as the never ending policeman
of the world, which I don't.
That's not.
My foreign policy view, I thought it wasn't
the view of a lot of trumpets when it was
Trump saying we're going to get out of there
now, all of a sudden those same people have
changed their mind.
I have not changed my mind on this.
Trump should have left.
Biden did leave.
Obama should have left, but he didn't.
OK, now, of course, the right is going after
Joe Biden.
Well, yeah, Joe Biden is a Democrat.
They're going to go after Joe Biden.
Yes, this is a crisis, but it would have been
the same crisis under Donald Trump.
We're seeing all the normal experts on foreign
policy come forward and say, oh, we should
have stayed.
This is a humiliation for Biden, should have
gotten out differently.
I have a completely different perspective
without denying that this has not gone well
because it hasn't gone well.
We rarely see presidents act this decisively
in getting us out of a commitment around the
world.
When presidents act decisively, it's usually
to start an incursion and it's considered
patriotic by the right.
When George W. Bush said on my order, we have
started attacks in Iraq after 9/11 and all
of this.
Wow.
Decisive and powerful.
Well, hold on a second.
Is it decisive and powerful to start an incursion
without actually thinking through the consequences
the way George W. Bush did?
This is the opposite, but it is decisive.
Joe Biden has drawn a line and is getting
us out of what George W. Bush started, what
Barack Obama didn't end, what Donald Trump
didn't end.
Biden is ending it in the first year of his
presidency.
And that's good.
And the situation has become very chaotic
and now Joe Biden has to figure out what to
do, but remember that the status quo before
we left was not some utopia for the Afghan
population, 200000 Afghans killed since we
went in.
It's been chaotic for years in Afghanistan,
but nobody was paying attention.
And now suddenly people are saying it only
just got chaotic because Joe Biden decided
to leave.
That's wrong.
It got more chaotic, without a doubt.
And now we have pundits and so-called experts
saying the least interesting things.
Just stay, stay for a month, stay for a year,
stay for another 20 years.
How is that even considered remotely serious
unless your view of American foreign policy
is uber interventionist?
That's not my foreign policy.
Joe Biden did a good thing by leaving left,
right.
And corporate media in their own ways are
slamming him.
But the decision was the right one.
Now you have to figure out what to do with
the chaos.
All the same.
People who ignored this for decades are now
jumping in like they've been paying attention
and saying we should be staying or we should
have left this way or we should have let gimme
a break, guys.
This is the same media that mostly rode willingly
into George W. Bush's Iraq war who are now
saying, oh, let's stay in Afghanistan, give
me a break.
There are real problems.
I don't understate for a second the dire situation
that is happening in Afghanistan.
Life lost tragedy, but we've had that for
20 years and barely a peep from a lot of these
same people.
Now, it's a cynical, uninformed attempt to
just go after Joe Biden.
Joe Biden deserves criticism in all of this,
but leaving was the right decision.
Trump should have left, Obama should have
left, resist the urge to demand that something
be either perfect or terrible.
OK, reality is more complicated and it's too
complicated for the really predictable, boring,
hot takes that we are seeing, including from
all sorts of corporate media with various
different political stripes.
We're going to keep talking about it this
week.
By the way, one last thing.
I got a few emails from people saying, David,
why haven't you talked about Afghanistan the
first week of this crisis?
I was gone.
I just I was just wasn't here.
My guest hosts talked about it.
Since getting back, I've done nine segments
on Afghanistan.
This today is number 10.
Give me a break, guys.
Find something else to complain about.